他の外国人の悪口を一切言わない外国人に
あったことがない口の中をヤケドせずに
たこ焼きパックを完食したことが2時間
並んでマジで正解だったなといったことが
ないなまはげを楽しむ子供を見たことか家
の中でゴキブリを見た時に正気を保った
ことがで8 e 街の目的でお台場に行く
人間のことを聞いたことが赤の他人と政治
家のことで功労したことがもう meme
化してるけどマジで fax を使わない
会社で働いたことがなくこだわりのって
いう言葉を使わない食品広告を見たことか
地震が起こったときにそうについて
つぶやかない人間に会ったことがない
てか今揺れたスーパーのレジを担当して
いる店員さんとをペンキについてお
しゃべりしたことが今日はなんでもない
です住所変更をネットでできる銀行を使っ
たことがないパナソニックのノートパソコ
を使わないサラリーマを見たことが
そうそうそのトラック part が丸い
やつ
もしかしてこの動画をそれで見てる
toeic スコアと話す能力が同等で
ある人間にあったことが富士山登ったこと
がない
なぜかというと富士山登ったけど案外楽
だったっていう言葉を一切聞いたことが
ないか日本語で話しかけてくる酔っ払った
おじいさんに遭遇したことが
エヴァンゲリオンが好きでその解説もでき
るって言う人間と話したことセクせぬセリ
を使って英語を勉強しない女性にあった
ことが学校銃撃について心配したこと金は
将来は年金だけで大丈夫だろうと思った
ことが dj krush のすばらしさ
がわかっている人に会ったことがない
そもそも dj krush を知って
いる人間にあったことだけはうらやましい
その日焼けという褒め言葉を聞いたことが
ないんだもう慣れたよ9電車はっていう
言葉を聞いたことがない外来語を使わずに
営業が出来る人と話したことがあこれ
ビジネスパース遊ぶ
来週じゃなくて今からと言われたことが
ないコンビニ弁当一切食べずに3日以上
過ごしたことか初対面で日本語お上手です
ねと言われない外国人を見たことがあるん
me